[music]
Could you spare a second?
So will you please listen
to the story of Cara Thiya?
She called for freedom
She a four-legend
Dreaming of splendid adventure
Will the prophecy manifest?
Will I be the maiden who was blessed?
And I, down the glory path
Bring all the red brightness back
I've heard all the enemies in sight
There is no turning back this time
Will I realize?
Will the world be placed on my head?
One day we shall cheer and dance
We can draw a forever light
[music]
I've seen nothing but a vicious light
Here comes the growling, dark, tight
The more pain she feels, the clearer she sees
Halo's of divine or fading
I can't hear a bell of faith sound
It's high time to turn it around
I'll carry on a glorious journey
With the blessed and wished by my side
Won't accept the faith that is set
There is no turning back this time
This will feel like it will realize
Truth in my heart never dies
Oh, there's no all the veils of lies
With the silver sword in my eyes
Oh, and I, mine falls in me
Grab me and lies, my goal shins miss
I'm still that girl, carrying the hopes
I'll break the shackles, free the souls
Trapped in those dark walls
[music]
Nothing can stop me walking down this path
Bringing on the rim less seems back
Won't accept the faith that is set
There is no turning back this time
It will be true, it will be true
Be a closure for this myth or one
Maybe she'll cheer and dance
Making joy forever love
[music]